so I went shopping with Leila the other
day my wife she was picking a pair of
shoes and she was like ah I don't really
know and the shoe salesman said
something that was so beautiful and
Layla said listen it's not about the
money I'm just not sure if I like the
shoes that much and the shoe smells and
said this she said well if we were
giving all these shoes away for free
would you take them she was like whoa I
mean sure if they were free and she was
like right then it's not not about the
money consider selling tickets to your
wedding that cover the cost of every
single person you want so instead of
having a budget and having to limit to
only the amount of people you can afford
every single person can pay for
themselves and even maybe a little extra
to put a down payment on a house or
start a new business rather than having
stuff that one time and you'll never use
you can have an investment that you can
use for Life the one rule my wife and I
have above all lovers in terms of making
decisions we both come to an agreement
or we don't move forward and that goes
for Investments it goes for business
decisions and it goes for social events
I think the quality of our decision says
benefit as a result